et cette invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
Lucas au bain bonjour bienvenue sur ce
plateau vous êtes directeur de recherche
à l'IRIS docteur en études slave je
signale votre dernier livre sorti il y a
quelques mois qui s'appelle géopolitique
de la Russie qui est sorti aux éditions
de La Découverte le bombardement de ni
pro Damien ok disait à l'instant a fait
au moins 40 morts c'était dimanche tous
des civils et l'inspirer à volody
mirzelinski ses propos tenus en russe à
l'intention donc de l'opinion publique
russe on l'écoute et on en reparle juste
après
je veux dire à tous ceux en Russie et
deux Russie qui même maintenant n'ont
pas pu prononcer ne serait-ce que
quelques mots pour condamner cette
erreur bien qu'il voit et qu'on prenne
tout parfaitement votre silence lâche
votre tentative d'attendre que cela se
passe n'aboutira qu'au fait qu'un jour
ces mêmes terroristes viendront vous
chercher le mal est très sensible à la
lâcheté le mal se souvient toujours de
ceux qui le craignent ou qui de négocier
et quand il viendra pour vous il n'y
aura personne pour vous protéger
cette intervention inspire deux
questions les Russes si tenter qu'on
puisse parler des Russes dans un pays de
150 millions d'habitants ont-ils pu
entendre ces mots
alors très probablement ils ont pu les
entendre évidemment on sait que les
Russes aujourd'hui ont accès à
différents cas de l'information on a
évidemment les télévisions d'État donc
contrôlées par le gouvernement qui
probablement utilisent ces paroles mais
sans les transformer finalement font en
sorte que ça aille dans le sens de la
doxa au pouvoir enfin de l'idéologie au
pouvoir entre guillemets et puis on a
aussi la possibilité d'aller sur sur
Internet en utilisant des VPN donc pour
contourner la censure finalement et
obtenir des informations différentes
donc ça c'est une possibilité après le
problème étant que quand vous êtes noyé
dans la masse d'informations
distribué par le Kremlin forcément c'est
difficile de faire la part des choses et
en l'occurrence Zelenski est toujours
présenté finalement comme un néonazi
qu'il faut destituer pour pouvoir
finalement libérer les Ukrainiens du
Zoug des Américains de l'OTAN etc
l'autre question c'est après 11 mois de
guerre mot qu'on ne peut toujours pas
prononcer en Russie est-ce que ce que
disait l'inscris peut raisonner
c'est toujours difficile de le savoir
effectivement le problème c'est que
l'espace informationnel russe il est
actuellement clos que on a des
difficultés nous-mêmes
occidentaux à avoir les informations
assez fiables sur la façon dont
l'opinion russe reçoit toutes ces
informations ce qu'on sait par contre
c'est que jusqu'à présent le pacte
tacite qui existait entre Vladimir
Poutine et sa population c'était la
politique c'est quelque chose dont on
s'occupe et vous en contrepartie citoyen
russe finalement vous avez une forme de
stabilité il s'avère que depuis novembre
dernier depuis la mobilisation partielle
finalement la guerre malgré le fait
qu'on ne puisse pas utiliser ce mot la
guerre est rentrée dans toutes les
maisons en Russie puisque aujourd'hui
300 000 personnes ont été mobilisés ce
qui correspond finalement à énormément
d'hommes même à l'échelle de la
Fédération de Russie et de fait plus
personne ne peut ignorer qu'il y a un
conflit qui se déroule actuellement à
l'est de l'Ukraine après est-ce que
l'opinion publique ruse elle va changer
parce qu'elle a évoluer en 11 mois pour
le moment on ne peut malheureusement pas
le savoir et c'est la réponse la plus
honnête que un chercheur puisse vous
faire aujourd'hui malheureusement je
sais qu'on aimerait bien avoir plus
d'informations mais on ne peut pas on ne
peut pas le savoir tout simplement parce
que depuis le début mars 2022 on a une
loi en Russie qui interdit une opinion
qui irait contre
l'opération militaire spéciale qui se
déroule actuellement à l'est de
l'Ukraine donc de fait si vous avez un
sondage qui vous dit par exemple que 50
% la population russe serait contre le
régime de Vladimir Poutine qui serait
pardon pour le régime de Vladimir
Poutine évidemment qu'on ne peut pas
répondre autrement puisque vous risquez
finalement si vous dites que vous n'êtes
pas d'accord vous risquez d'être
emprisonné ou d'avoir des millions de
roubles d'amende donc de fait
actuellement on peut se fier au
mouvement de population c'est à dire que
on a vu par exemple à peu près un
million de personnes fuir la Russie
depuis le début du conflit et notamment
depuis la mobilisation partielle c'est
un signal effectivement qui montre une
partie de la population n'est pas en
accord avec son Président ou alors on ne
voulait pas aller faire la guerre en
Ukraine est-ce que la côte des
popularité qui a baissé croit à
l'automne de Vladimir Poutine peut être
un indice un indicateur ça peut être
indicateur après cette cote de
popularité elle reste de toute façon
élevée depuis
75% à peu près depuis que Vladimir
Poutine est arrivé au pouvoir en 2000
jusqu'à aujourd'hui de toute façon elle
a toujours été au-dessus de 55 60 %
d'opinion favorable finalement donc
la fiabilité de ladite alors on ne voit
plus aujourd'hui les manifestations
qu'on a vu à Saint-Pétersbourg notamment
aux premières semaines de la guerre au
mois de voilà la gare a commencé au mois
de février mais on avait des
manifestations en mars en avril
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire est-ce que ça
veut dire que le Kremlin a gagné la
bataille de l'opinion ça pose la
question de l'efficacité de la
propagande d'État ou est-ce que ça veut
dire que l'opposition est tellement
atomisée que de toute façon elle n'a
aucun moyen de s'exprimer alors il faut
bien comprendre que depuis 2000 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui le pouvoir russe est devenu
peu à peu autoritaire c'est à dire qu'il
ne l'était pas au début des années 2010
qu'on avait une au début des années 2000
qu'on avait une forme de démocratie qui
était contrôlée mais qui existait quand
même puis à partir de 2012 et la
troisième élection de Vladimir Poutine
tous les canaux d'opposition potentielle
ont été peu à peu refermé donc
l'opposition politique n'a plus pu
s'exprimer l'opposition médiatique non
plus et dans la rue les manifestants
étaient heureux à peu réprimés
aujourd'hui quand vous allez dans la rue
en Russie vous avez une forte
probabilité de vous faire arrêter de
passer une nuit une semaine un mois
voire plus en prison de fait évidemment
chacun pèse le pour et le contre si on
est contre le pouvoir russe aujourd'hui
peut-être que la meilleur moyen de
s'opposer n'est pas d'aller dans la rue
mais de potentiellement de diffuser des
messages sur les réseaux sociaux
potentiellement fuir à l'étranger pour
pouvoir parler
librement etc etc on a vu les médias
d'opposition notamment russe par exemple
qui sont partis
s'exilaient dans les pays baltes
notamment en Lettonie pour pouvoir
s'exprimer librement après évidemment
quand vous êtes pas au sein même de la
société russe du territoire la
Fédération de Russie forcément vous
n'avez pas les mêmes informations
puisque si le vase est fermé pour les
Russes vers l'extérieur il est aussi
fermé pour l'extérieur vers l'intérieur
de la Fédération possible vous disiez
tout à l'heure que le rapport à la
guerre avait peut-être changé quand la
guerre était entrée dans les foyers
russes avec la mobilisation il y a
quelques mois on disait à l'époque quand
les Russes les babouchka notamment
verrez les cercueils de leur fils
revenir parce qu'il y en a on sait qu'il
y a bien sûr des milliers de soldats
russes qui sont morts en Ukraine
peut-être la les choses changeraient on
n'a pas vu non plus les choses changer
alors on a vu qu'on a vu quand même
quelques éléments à partir du moment où
il y a eu la mobilisation partielle on a
vu des manifestations de justement de
babouchka comme comme les ateliers
notamment dans les républiques de la
Fédération de Russie à savoir les
républiques ethniques ou vivent les
minorités comme les tchétchen comme les
Tatars comme les buryades par exemple on
sait que c'est minorités ethniques sont
envoyées au front de façon
mais on sait aussi que elles ne sont pas
forcément concernées de la même façon
par cette opération militaire spéciale
qui finalement concerne le peuple slave
en tout cas selon Vladimir Poutine or
quand vous êtes tata tchétchène pour
regarde vous n'êtes pas forcément
concerné par cela on a vu énormément
justement de babouchka notamment à
grosse ni par exemple en Tchétchénie
aller demander des comptes finalement à
pourquoi
aux autorités locales pourquoi nos fils
sont envoyés à la guerre quelle est
cette guerre quel est le sens de cette
guerre finalement et pour le moment la
propagande de la Dyna Poutine tient on a
la sensation globalement que ça tient
néanmoins certains signaux faibles
laissent penser que cette logique de
dons contre nous entre les républiques
éloignées de l'État central qui doivent
rendre des comptes finalement au Kremlin
soit en train parfois s'effriter même si
malheureusement il est trop tôt pour
tirer des coups
annonce vraisemblablement une nouvelle
campagne militaire avec peut-être une
mobilisation supplémentaire et là on
verra aussi si ces signaux dont vous
parlez
se renforce la garantie de survie
politique de Vladimir Poutine
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est forcément
la victoire militaire non pas forcément
il y a fort à parier que si il y a des
fêtes militaires alors le Poutine la
transformera en victoire politique alors
ça peut paraître un peu absurde et
contradictoire dit comme ça mais
Vladimir Poutine c'est un émetteur
continue de sa propre histoire qu'il est
en train de construire en fait donc il
n'a pas peur de l'incohérence
aujourd'hui il se dit en guerre contre
l'Occident mais il ne se dit pas en
guerre contre l'Ukraine alors
effectivement si vous perdez contre
l'Occident de manière générale et contre
les États-Unis finalement il n'y a pas à
rougir de la défaite puisque l'Occident
représente à peu près 66% du PIB mondial
et je ne parle même pas d'armement
forcément quand on a la première
puissance militaire américaine en face
enfin première puissance militaire de la
planète en face à savoir la puissance
américaine donc il pourrait essayer de
transformer cette défaite en victoire
politique et forcément il y aurait
surface peu de personnes pour le
contester néanmoins on sait aussi que
tous les journalistes qui sont sur place
actuellement en Russie disent que les
Russes ne comprennent pas pourquoi cette
opération militaire spéciale prend
autant de temps ne comprennent pas
pourquoi par exemple on bombarde pas le
palais présidentiel de zen qui pourquoi
on a réussi pas finalement à le démettre
de ses fonctions pourquoi on a réussi
pas on n'a pas réussi à prendre Kiev au
début de la guerre bref autant
interrogation qui laisse penser que
peut-être que malgré le fait que
Vladimir Poutine contrôle les médias
contrôlent sa parole etc il pourrait à
un moment donné se retrouver limité et
les incohérences les unes ajoutées aux
autres pourraient finalement faire
vaciller son pouvoir merci beaucoup
Lucas au bon d'être venu ce matin nous
partager ces pistes de réflexion
directeur de recherche à l'IRIS et je
rappelle le nom de votre ouvrage
géopolitique de la Russie aux éditions
de La Découverte merci encore une très
bonne journée à vous on se retrouve avec
Damien coquet nous pour la suite de
Paris direct et un nouveau journal à
tout de suite
[Musique]